hello everyone and welcome to fake news
with Josh mokuba the first and only 100%
factual fake news program on the
internet and maybe TV it kind of depends
on how you watch the Internet and
recently the movie Aquaman passed 1
billion dollars at the global box office
and as such the internet deemed it
important to make sure you all know just
exactly why Aquaman made that much money
when it was only sort of well liked I
don't know I haven't really seen it
that being said here is a totally
arbitrary list about why it made a
billion dollars number 5 swimming people
loved swimming every year high net worth
individuals invest in Beach lake and
river houses in order to look at water
in hopes that one day they can swim in
it not only that but each year the
swimming lesson industry pays got close
to three billion dollars in illegal cash
transactions pocketed by teenagers who
are still claimed by dependents by their
parents this love of swimming has
convinced children all over the world
that they themselves can become an
Aquaman or part of the Aquaman
fraternity this does not include the
people that have actually tried to find
a lost city of Atlantis because this
place does not exist many people think
that it does but it doesn't I had an
uncle who tried he borrowed a lot of
money from my dad and died before he
could pay it back my family still pissed
about it number 4
Amber Heard has red hair red hair seems
to be something people like I've seen
some people with bright red hair or
light red hair pink hair that looks red
in certain lights and of course this has
led to a large group of people embracing
amber herds red hair in Aquaman this
overlooked sub-sect of the population
that has red hair has rarely been
represented in movies and the recent
string of attacks on gingers and non
gingers alike with red hair is a
societal injustice but since amber herds
turn as Queen Hammond and the red-headed
people of the world have united in unity
this movie's diversity is 100%
responsible for more people with red air
venturing to the theaters number 3
number three the Game of Thrones effect
the game of Thrones effect is a real
thing a recent survey taken by the world
Census Bureau states that 99.9% of the
population watches Game of Thrones
making it the most-watched show behind
the series finale of mash and of course
the one where of Ross wears leather
pants with this game of Thrones effect
most everyone saw the billboard for
Aquaman and immediately thought oh this
is Game of Thrones under water and thus
we must partake as to not look foolish
at a dinner party with friends who serve
food on plates with decorations on them
or as my parents called it the plates
which shall not be touched with this
Game of Thrones
underwater comparison the large
population of people who still complain
that the 97 chapters of the book which
were actually underwater but HBO didn't
have a budget force finally got their
underwater iron throne and thus 1
billion dollars number 2 communicating
with fish now the old adage goes give a
man a fish feed him for a day teach a
man to talk to fish and watch him make 1
billion dollars in Aquaman not only does
he talk to fish but he also rides them
and uses their scales as body armor to
protect him from over salt exposure
common with most wetsuits or people with
extreme perspiration issues the ability
to communicate with fish has long been
an urban legend with those in the scuba
snuba snorkel free diving community but
with this story based on true life and
true events we now know it's possible
and because of this 1 billion dollars
are now being invested into ocean force
a special ops program at local pools
which will in fact teach us all how to
talk to fish in hopes that one day we
can finally merge our two worlds in
harmony no longer will we have to live
in fear of a fish revolution similar to
that of late 17th century Rhode Island
it happened and finally The Little
Mermaid cross over your number one
reason that Aquaman crossed the 1
billion dollar threshold The Little
Mermaid crossover now we all know that
Disney is currently the most powerful
company in the world
right behind Chipotle and their upcoming
re-release of the long-awaited Little
Mermaid sequel is being talked about
from New York to Los Angeles and London
to Tokyo but what the world was not
prepared for
was the appearance of the Little Mermaid
in Aquaman and of course the hero turned
villain in the form of Sebastian the
crab some called that lovely Jamaican
crab a friend to all but just like Jar
Jar Binks he was in fact a Sith and
because of this crossover with the
Aquaman world we now have the first ever
shared universe between DC Comics Marvel
Star Wars and Disney Animation something
Gerald Ford talked about in his
inaugural jest in 1972 and for those top
five reasons Aquaman and his gang of
Aquaman have reigned supreme at the box
office earning over 1 billion dollars
will the Meg be next we shall see
i'm josh mokuba and that's fake news
you